Are you between 16 and 17 years old
then put this date in your agenda
and don't plan parties
because on June 9
Are you still obliged to vote for it
European Parliament
it has decided that constitutionally
because your underage voters
actually not allowed otherwise
then treat several year old voters
just like the adults
so also risk
young people who do not show up for the elections
1 sanktie I SAY of course show up
because in our country 1 attendance requirement applies
that means you have to come to the voting booth
but you are not obliged to actually vote 1
to release
do you think it is good that young people are also obliged
have to vote